ladies and gentlemen we have reached
the second day of the semifinals in the
skilling open
and boy is it exciting nakamura
and napoli need to win their matches in
order to
take the games to blitz and perhaps
armageddon
they have to win in order to stay in the
tournament
and the game i wanted to show you was
jan
against the magnus their very first game
a very thrilling and
exciting game that i'm looking forward
to show you guys
so e4 e5 and out of three knight c6
bishop b5 this is that spanish opening
very common of course knight f6 is
slightly
uh more solid the
um the berlin defense but magnus he
he didn't want to play that he played a6
which is the other main move in
this position no 97 this time
so a6 bishop a4 knight f6
everything is theory so far castles
uh he is kind of protecting this pawn
and directly it doesn't really well
black doesn't win a pawn
although this is a line which is uh
interesting
it goes like d4 b5
bishop b3 d5 d takes e5 and bishop e6
this is called the
open spanish and it's a completely
different story
certainly possible to play for for black
a very interesting
line but it's not that common so bishop
b7 is by far the most common move
and now black is for real threatening to
take on
e4 so there are two ways to defend
uh which are both very popular the first
move is
e1 and this second one is d3 which is
what yan goes for
i can mention that rookie one has been
the main move
for many many years it is perhaps the
most critical move
and the game usually goes like b5 bishop
b3
d6 c3 castles and here white waits with
d4
he prefers to play h3 first in order to
avoid bishop g4
and here black has several moves for
example knight a5
knight b8 and bishop b7 all of those are
huge main lines uh massive theory
and this line here which is quite new
with 97
has become very popular on top level at
least 2600
players have played this a lot so
these positions are very interesting
very rich and both strategical and
tactical elements
i find the positions very difficult to
play with both colors to be honest
they're very weird it's uh it's not so
easy to play them
spanish positions are very complicated
but this is the uh most critical way to
go
but d3 is uh by by all means this is not
a bad move it's not
a move that's not critical either it was
played a lot a few years ago
not as much as it used to be played but
it's uh
it's a way to try for an advantage it's
slightly slower and
perhaps a bit more strategical
uh but the plan remains the same it's
very similar to
an italian really white will play c3
knight bd2 rookie one knight f1 knight
g3 and perhaps h3 later and then also
strike in the center of d4
so let's see what black does it plays d6
c3
castles knight bd2 all of these moves
have been
expected and rookie 8
you notice that this bishop here is
slightly poor so black wants to improve
the position
of the position of the bishop so he
prefers to get it to g7 so we'll play
bishop f8 g6 bishop g7
a very common move in the spanish pretty
much always
played another another plan is to play
b5
knight a5 and c5 also
very common as well
so let's see what happened rookie one
bishop f8
and here yanni pomnacci makes a very
interesting choice
um the most well if you're gonna
continue the plan
h3 is what makes sense to avoid bishop
g4
but instead he's decided to strike in
the center
immediately with d4 which i don't think
is a bad move it's a very interesting
decision uh perhaps even the best move
in the position
b5 bishop c2 and magnus he
he goes for an interesting
a try here he takes d4 it's certainly
not a bad move at all it just makes
the position slightly different if you
want to
remain mysterious as i like to call it
then you can play bishop b7
and later maybe knight b8 knight bd7
because the knight is better placed on
d7 than on c6
and knight a5 is now not so desirable
because you don't get not a5 of a tempo
due to the bishop having moved to
to c2 on the other hand you could get
take on d4 followed by knight b4 in a
few cases
so e takes d4 c takes d4 bishop g4
pinning the knight so knight takes d4 is
a threat
this is prevented with knight f1
magnus goes for g6 as i said this plan
with bishop g7 is
a very common very logical
magnus no yawn continues with knight g3
bishop g7 from from magnus which is
perhaps not the best move
uh in this position in particular
because of this bishop here
there is a pin on this knight janna
probably
has simply said that i don't care if you
take on f3 because i'll take back with
the g
pawn and this pawn structure here is
honestly pretty good for me
he doesn't care he doesn't think it is a
big deal
magnus he doesn't take it either which
means that his judgment is probably
probably right and
also this these pawns could become quite
dangerous with f4 d5
e5 perhaps in in the future
but uh he had this uh interesting move
here with knight b4
wanting to take the bishop you never
want to give away this bishop so bishop
b1
is the automatic response and then black
takes his chance to play c5
that is the point of knight before
really and
these positions are not so so easy for
black for white
knight c6 could come now and black would
get a nice square on d4
so the way to continue would be to play
something like d5
so knight c6 is not possible it looks
like this
this knight is out of play but it's not
really true because i can play a5 and
that put my knight
to on a6 so there are no problems
and now i have a decent amount of space
here on
on the queen side and perhaps even a
slightly better position
so a knight before would have been a
very interesting move but bishop g7 is
what the magnus does which is a very
logical move
of course but not the best one the ship
e3
knight d7 so he wants to take and then
take on d4
jan he doesn't really care about that
either he plays rook c1
bishop takes f3 and again he doesn't
care he thinks that the
the this pawn structure here is alright
for
for white and he is indeed correct
this is not bad at all and if black is
not careful
then it could end and uh this could end
very badly
uh so um well we're now threatening
some things here so black needs to be
quite careful he needs to be
straightforward if not he's going to
have a very bad position like if he was
going to play something like this then
i'm just going to push my pawns
and the computer already says it's
waiting for white which is kind of
kind of crazy but not very surprising
all of these pawns are just
far far too strong e5 comes f5 and
the game is over very quickly and same
goes with something like knight
a5 b3 simply and then f4 later and e5
very bad for black as well so back is
forced to play this move
and it's very difficult to protect this
pawn because if i play
knight e2 quintex f3 is possible
so when jan chooses to play bishop b3
so this is a tactical sequence knight
takes d4 bishop takes d4
queen takes d4 and rook takes e7 in
return
white has gotten a very nice bishop here
on the b3 and i broke
an active rook on c7 black has gotten
some nice squares here on c5
and on e5 while these pawns could become
slightly weak
because this center is not dangerous
anymore or not that dangerous anymore
due to the fact that this d4 pawn here
is gone rook k7 is a very good defensive
move notice how both of these
pieces here they uh protect
the the rook on a7 so if i i'm going to
take the bishop still defends a7
but the outtakes on a7 and then on d6
and yes officially
he's officially pawn up although this
doesn't last long due to bishop takes b2
and the position
is balanced it's a very interesting
position where anything can happen
but the objective evaluation is uh
equality here
so well played by both sides a good game
f4 by janna pomnacchi knight c5 by
magnus
logical he gets activity is also
threatening to take
the bishop so jan doesn't want to allow
that he plays bishop d5
and now magnus uses his chance to play
bishop d4
and we have a very interesting position
it's uh i noticed that i've said that
quite a lot but
it's just a very exciting game where
anything really can happen
i do like black hair knight d3 could
come attacking quite a few things
and it's not so easy to be white
you also may wonder what happens if i
take here and then on d4 but this is not
so dangerous because i have knight e6
and knight xf4 or quintex f4
where black at least will stand slightly
better so yeah plays rookie too
knight d3 and then king g2 his plan is
actually to play king
f3 in a few cases just to protect this
weak pawn on f4 and
it's not so dumb magnus plays the
the move king g7 which is uh
alright it's not the best move the best
move would have been to play queen b6
with the idea of
getting this end game this endgame is
very comfortable for black
it's even clearly better due to white
having several weaknesses in his camp
and these two pawns here could become
quite strong
for example king f3 something like
knight b4 is unpleasant
could take the bishop in the future or
simply just if the bishop moves
a5 a4 and knight c6 knight d4 is not so
uh so simple even rook d8 and i mean
black is pretty active
and i like black but
and he has indeed a clearly better
position in that endgame
it's not so easy to evaluate king g7
also makes sense
rook d2 bishop c5 queen c6
and this is a kind of a tactical
continuation here
i'm sure you have to see this uh in this
position
so john is thinking he sees that bishop
c5 is a threat followed by a knight
except for
but he feels like after rook d2 it works
out for me and magnus disagrees
it works out for him he says so bishop
c5 knight
xf4 king of three i'm attacking two
pieces the rook
and the knight and what do i do now is
black
how do you defend this and it's not easy
first of all i can choose to sacrifice
an exchange of rookie six bishop takes
knight x and
uh i'm probably alright this black due
to the
black squares being significantly weak
so it would be
way better to have this pawn on e3
instead of e4
but the pawn is on e4 and the position
is roughly equal
if this happens another way is to play
bishop b4
this was works tactically uh
it's kind of crazy why it works but
something like rook c2
simply queen b8 and the sole reason why
this works
is tactic tactically because i if rook
takes
b4 i have rook c8 and then rook c3 next
and this king is completely naked and
it's
lost it's just a very wide line
so i think magnus didn't see that it's a
very difficult move to find
after rook b-turn that's why i didn't
play bishop b4 i think
because if i take the rook then
obviously this is good for black i'm
sure he saw this this is not so hard to
see
because i'm threatening to take the
bishop and then play f6
so queen e5 f6 and then i take the
bishop and there's no attack i'm sure
magnus saw that
but rook b2 is a logical way to go and
the only move is queen b8 and that's
very difficult to find because you have
to see this in this position
so magnus he played rook t8 instead
which is an
inaccuracy however it's not the end of
the world
and indeed if the king takes f4 rook d6
the position is balanced
but what happens next is uh is very
remarkable
so jani has two moves to move the queen
he can go to e8 or he can go to c8 you
can also go to a8 but then i take and
take the rook
so that's not possible so if i play
queen e c8 the position is objectively a
draw
after this move bishop takes f2 however
this is not always the case
here yanni play queen e8 which is a
losing move
but after the bishop takes f2 white is
in fact
winning it's crazy how this is
winning now but with the queen on c8
it's not winning
that's a very it's very strange but i
think the primary reason is that when
the queen is on e8 we're threatening to
take on f7 which often leads to mate
after queen f8
and here black is winning
so if you want to you can pause the
video and see if you can find it
it is not such a difficult move to find
if you see the idea
because there are two ideas behind the
move
remember queen eight was not possible
because the work was hanging
that is an important thing to keep in
mind so if i play
if i play like um if i play the best
move here
queen 27 i'm now threatening rook d8
check and winning the queen a rook e6 i
mean sorry
um i'm also threatening group 65 all
kind of discoveries
but the huge threat here the huge threat
is rook t8 and it's impossible to guard
yourself for both because if i play
queen e5 simply f6
and black wins and let's say i move the
king then rook d8 comes
and the only way i can defend my queen
and save it is queen c6
but i can simply take and take on f2 and
this is completely winning for black
so queen c7 is the move magnus should
have seen
um i think he was low on time at this
point that's why i missed it but he
definitely should have seen it
it's not such a very difficult move to
find but you know when you're in there
in the moment
and yeah you are low on time and it's
easy to miss things you know
normally never would miss and uh it's
the case here
indeed uh the hard thing to see is that
you're threatening rook d8 that's
the hard thing to see but i'm sure he
thought that bishop xf2 was good so he
just went for it
but this is losing due to the brilliant
move by jan here
the brilliant brilliant move and a very
logical move
is king g4 and normally
this is not losing because queen e3 here
would have led to a draw
but that doesn't happen here because of
queen takes f7 is mate
so that's the reason why queen c8 is a
draw but it is the best move
queen c8 prevents queen g7 that's why
it's not losing queen e8 loses to queen
c7
but magnus didn't find it because of
that
he is losing because he can no longer
play queen e3 and if he cannot do that
he's a piece down with too little
compensation
the problem is that after rook f6 i
simply play e5 i chase away the rook
and black doesn't have enough for the
piece
h5 king h3 the king is perfectly safe
the black king the white king is
perfectly safe
and the advantage is hitting
astronomical heights here for white
rook f4 e6 is a very good move
try to open up the position even more
and
it's never dangerous it never is
because if i simply if i play something
like queen e3
which always looks dangerous i can just
take here
if i take the rook then this is going to
be checkmate after f8
rook takes 27 check and this is a mate
in a few moves
might as well just show it that's a
pretty mate
there we go nice mate so f takes c6
is more or less forced and then simply
bishop takes
and now this king is weak king queen g8
and knight takes h5
a lot of moves and after bishop d4
the beautiful move knight takes h5 and
black is officially mated
after takes rook g2 rookie six should be
three
and uh magnus resigned uh it's just mate
it was a very very fun game
janipamyanchi
is closer to um to the blitz match
he needs in order to hang on this is
very exciting stuff
a very fun game which could have gone
either way i think both players played
very well
um magnus had his chance with um
with knight before earlier i think i
like this quite a bit
but also later with queen b6
trading off the queens here was kind of
a key moment for
for magnus because this position here is
just extremely complicated where it's
very difficult as a human being to play
this
and as i said bishop b4 as uh the reason
he missed it
is that he didn't see queen b8 in this
position which is
which is which is a computer move
uh very difficult to see and after rook
d6
the blunder queen e8 he should have seen
queen c7
but again it's not so easy when you are
in the moment and
in standard chess it would have easily
found it uh
and it's just this was the difference
between a victory and a loss because he
didn't find it
i ended up having a lost position and
that was just one mistake pretty much
one mistake
magnus himself is going to say he played
a very bad game
i disagree i think he found a lot of
good moves there
with rook k7 and he defended very well
but in time trouble it happens you mess
up and you blunder that's just the way
it is and rapid
great game uh for john aponachido who
is closer to qualifying and
it will be exciting to see if he manages
to take the games to blitz and then
perhaps even armageddon
stay tuned